welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars and or episode 7 which shows why
people in Miami do not go for walks are
you crazy drive or just plant your beach
chair and wait for the hurricane
I'm gonna break down this episode shot
by shot for all the Star Wars Easter
eggs and just cool visual details that
you might have overlooked we opened back
in the home of Cyril Karn just like the
opening shot of episode 5 except this
time there's no ray of sunshine warming
Cyril's face this time you can better
see the Imperial action figures on his
shelf evoking these Stormtrooper doll
that Jen erso has on lamu in Rogue one
Cyril pours himself more blue bantha
milk cereal while his mother 80
critiques his clothes
to ground seed
the collar what about it it's high
you've had it right tailored
everything says something Cyril as he
did with his primor uniform Cyril
tailored his suit and the color brown
does say something because Kyle Soler
told us in an interview that for
inspiration he looked at the patrols
between the wars referring to the Nazi
Brown Shirts Cyril sees the televised
news broadcast reporting the robbery on
aldani news media in the Star Wars
universe is not exactly common but the
Empire Day episode of rebels does
reference the Imperial holonet a
mandatory propaganda broadcast because
today is Empire Day celebrating the 15th
anniversary of the Galaxy salvation with
our great Emperor Palpatine ended the
Clone Wars and founded our glorious
Empire this news broadcast in Andor
could be part of the Imperial holonet
but this on-screen host doesn't have the
propagandists to expand that the
announcer in Rebels did just like those
of us on YouTube who have the balls to
show our faces have a bit more
credibility you're welcome we transition
from Cyril to detrimero suiting up
specifically the close-ups of her
tugging at her collar this is a nervous
tick that we saw her do in episode four
and I like this way of showing how Dedra
and Cyril both prefer the choking
Imperial leash as if enjoying the
thought of Lord Vader giving them the
mighty treatment
and that whole choking Motif comes up in
this ISB speech be here this morning and
know that the only question we need to
answer is how tight to close our fist
this is Wolf fuel Lauren the longtime
Star Wars figure who first appeared in
the background of A New Hope but the
character was given more of a backstory
in Clone Wars as an officer in the
Republic navy serving alongside Obi-Wan
and Anakin on various missions but when
the Empire took over you Lauren resigned
its commission to become a colonel in
the ISB which is what his rank is now
you Lauren is also an ally to Grand
Admiral thrawn explored in Timothy
zahn's thrawn novels you Lauren will die
along with many of these characters on
the Death Star but thrawn is still alive
years after this during the New Republic
era in the mandalorians the actor
playing him probably going to be
revealed at some point in the next six
months so through you Lauren here we may
yet meet a live-action thrawn ulern
announces new empire-wide measures
attacks on sectors at Harbor partisan
activity revoking local customs and
traditions used as cover by rebels and
new powers granted from the emperor the
emperor will be convening an emergency
session of the Senate to propose a
legislation package of bills and
amendments that will free our hands in
all matters of surveillance search and
seizure this public order resentencing
directive or pord Parallels the passage
of the real world Patriot Act after 9 11
which critics felt paved the way for the
rise of the surveillance State an
encroachment on privacy and civil
liberties Dedra realizes this
overreaction was the Rebel's true
intention
that's exactly what they want we're
treating what happened at aldani like a
robbery what would you call it
an announcement an announcement is the
is the Empire makes its announcements
like you Lawrence PRD in the news
broadcasts but the rebels forced them to
escalate dramatically into this putative
police state breaking that illusion of
normalization that until then was their
true power heightening all this into a
more outly open extreme conflict was
really the true announcement of the
rebels luthin listens to a radio
frequency with a robotic voice to mask
the person who's sending these messages
out military personnel at the Garrison
have been replaced and are being
interrogated by ISB for tracking devices
in the Escape Route disabled prior to
increasing hyperspace 134 azani
residents have been taken into custody
of the suspicion of betting the terms
this confirms that everyone who worked
on that Garrison was sacked in 134
aldanis which includes all of those
pilgrims and probably a lot more people
who got stuck in those pubs along the
way all of them have been detained for
questioning and you know what that
probably means CLIA announces mon mothma
is here without warning
wipe the smile off your face remember
Lou then when he's in character he's
always smiling but Leah knows the
difference between his character Smile
and his genuine smile so she's telling
him to keep those two separated and
notice how when Luton faces the window
where the driver chorus can see them he
maintains that phony grin but when he
turns and faces away from the window his
expression drops to his normal cold
demeanor mon matma apparently was kept
in the dark on the aldani mission and
Genevieve O'Reilly does such a good job
conveying the fear over that
he really likes
one now every episode we pointed out all
the berries Easter eggs in the shop
check out my past breakdowns for all of
them but I like how front and center you
can really see Jedi Master plow Coons
mask there but now you can also see a
white Jedi Temple guard mask on the
shelf behind him Lutheran exchanges the
two-faced deity art that he gave mon
Mothman back in episode 4 for the eau de
palan monk cudgel that he showed her at
that time and he says has anyone ever
made a weapon that wasn't used this is a
monk cudgel meaning a peaceful religious
figure still made this serrated weapon
similarly the Jedi lightsaber was meant
to be a defensive tool used by
peacekeepers but of course ended up
being weaponized Lutheran is basically
saying that when you're at War the point
of your scheming is for it to be
weaponized and for people to get hurt
luthin is essentially echoing mimics
talking points the Empire has been
choking us so slowly we're studying not
to notice
time has come to force their hand people
will suffer
that's the plan despite monmouth's
position as a realist I like how they
always maintain the empathy of her
character like she is now and will
always be the woman who Mourns the
bothans who died giving us this
information Cyril takes a new job at the
Bureau of Standards a vast field of
cubicles keeping track of data in the
Empire like weights and gauges
redundancy verification fuel impurity
the whole worker bee drone Vibe does
look like something out of Terry
gilliams Brazil but also with Silo data
entry in your cubicle very similar to
Severance on Apple TV plus I love that
show Cyril has to move out of the way of
a mouse droid and one of the other
workers around him does look like a blue
skinned chiss with light up glasses Cleo
makes her way across town the metro
station reads and orbesh please mind the
gap as doors are closing this station
actually was shot in the real world
McLaren Technology Center in Surrey the
ground floor of which was used for
Cyril's arrival back home in episode 4.
Clea passes a few Stormtroopers who
mutter some code to each other
yeah the second one said luh3417 7 which
was the name of the friend in thx1138
and George Lucas's first film thx1138
Cleo passes a hologram ad with orabesh
translating to Tasty pizzas pizzos are
the snack food that the woman asked
Cassie to go pick up later in the
episode and then that changes to a PSA
message from the Empire carry your chain
codes from the ISB chain codes is just
basically every person's ID and the
Empire is really the one who instituted
everyone having to have chain codes on
them at all times Claire notices the
chalk marking on the ground echoing the
chucked Jedi sigils marking the path for
Jedi fugitives and Obi-Wan Kenobi since
it recovers a speed scooter on all
Donnie and looks up to find herself in
the shadow of an arriving Imperial Star
Destroyer I like how the camera Shakes
as it passes overhead giving us a sense
of its magnitude the area where Cleo
meets Belle has these Brickstone
walkways and stucco pillars matching the
brutalist architecture built in London
during the Margaret Thatcher era like
the National Theater Vel is disappointed
Lutheran didn't show and she seems
annoyed that they aren't doing more to
honor tammerman Gorn or nimik Clea
orders Vel to kill Cassian gassian
returns to barracks and grades Marva and
b2emo potassium
B is so excited to see Cassian and he
lets out a little Droid purr when
Cassian Pats his head like a good boy at
her dinner party mod mothma meets with
her longtime friend from our Homeworld
of chandrilla take homea played by Ben
miles who played Peter Townsend in early
seasons of the crown man's daughter Lita
asked to be excused now all parents
seems to be the more likely of Mon's
family to turn on her his open
frustration with her seems more surface
level what surprised me if that's all it
really is with him and if Lena could be
the one to end up betraying mon either
by becoming an imperial Cadet or maybe
serving as a mentee to the grand vizier
or working in the offices of slymore or
the emperor kind of like the way he used
Anakin Skywalker to spy on the Jedi now
you guys have seen my videos enough to
know that I watched a lot of TV a lot of
movies and I rewatch everything a
bazillion times just in case I missed
something but depending on where you
live there's a lot of stuff that you
just can't watch unless you're using a
VPN and if you're using a VPN you really
should be using expressvpn so expressvpn
makes it so that your digital location
doesn't have to match your physical
location it protects your data from
hackers and keeps anybody from logging
what you're doing online and most
importantly it unlocks all kinds of
content that you might be missing out on
simply because of where you happen to be
logging in from like if you want to
watch Spirited Away on Netflix normally
if you're in the US you're out of luck
but with expressvpn all you've got to do
is just switch your location to the UK
you refresh a page and you're good to go
if you're in the UK switch your location
all of a sudden you can be watching
Vikings expressvpn is so easy to use all
you got to do is open the app and
connect with just one click it's a top
rated VPN provider rated number one by
tech radar find out how you can get
three months of expressvpn for free by
visiting expressvpn.com new rockstars or
by clicking the link in the description
below Iman catches up with her friend I
want to tell you something that only
three people in the Galaxy now they pass
through this wall decor that looks like
a spider web appropriate since mon is
talking about her own Rebel web Network
and seconds later Tay asks her if this
matters personal or political the camera
again frames them from behind that web
wall also makes us wonder who are the
three people in the Galaxy who know
about this we have to assume Lutheran
and Clea are two of them so who is that
third person probably bail Organa right
like they had that whole conversation
that deleted scene at the end of Revenge
of the city as mon ante passed the bar
you can see Perrin out of focus behind
them watching her talk to him and she
says I've learned from Palpatine I show
you the stone in my hand you miss the
knife at your throat I love this man has
recognized the political skill Palpatine
wielded to get to his high ranking
position Cassian sneaks into bix's shop
and he does the shape of the haircut not
to Signal her
hey
[Music]
cassia jog to stay ahead of a few
Stormtroopers and then flashes back to
this memory on Rick Street
this is not our podcast
don't worry don't worry we're just going
to raise their silly flag and fly away
the marching sounds are what draw him
into this memory just like the sounds of
B calling him Casa in episode one to
wake him up brought him back to qunari
then some interesting visual trickery
here though in this memory we see adult
Diego Luna shown a close-up but from
behind him and all the other shots needs
flashbacks they swap in a younger actor
to play Young Cassian Lucas Bond so that
means Cassian sees himself projecting
himself in the past from his present age
to relive the shout of trauma the trauma
that stays with him as an adult Pro
Republic protesters throw rocks at the
Troopers which in this flashback are not
Stormtroopers but Clone Troopers that
means this would be set in a very short
amount of time right at the end of the
Clone Wars when the empire was still
using clone troopers before Tarkin based
all of them out and replaced him with
Stormtrooper recruits that also means
unfortunately for clam and the
protesters that these guys aim is a hell
of a lot better Marvel wants to stay on
pharynx to resist the Imperial
occupation inspired by the rebel
successes on all Donnie she says that
she's tired of turning away from Rick's
road to avoid thinking about Clem's body
being hung up on display and casting
abruptly flashes back to that memory
cleans Frozen sleeves and close-ups this
is the second time a Star Wars title in
a row to show Imperial horses hanging a
criminal after we saw an Obi-Wan Kenobi
young Cassian charges at four clone
troopers with this pipe likely what led
to his incarceration before being forced
to fight a mimban among marva's hanging
plants is this ornament that looks a lot
like the hanging pendant over the
dashboard of her ship when she extracted
casting from Canary in episode 3. we get
this beautiful exchange between the
mother and son I won't have peace
I'll be worrying about you all the time
just love
nothing you can do about that and I just
have to single this out because it's so
rare in genre shows like this to get an
honest expression of the actual emotions
love manifest as yes it is another way
of saying what is grief if not love
persevering but this isn't a synthazoid
defining the term for us it's a mother
telling her son that we all have to live
with pain if we want to love people but
it's also her non-verbally telling him
that whenever he is gone she will always
worry about him and she will always love
him and there's nothing she can do about
that Marva leaves him with stop
searching for your sisters
fantasy there were no survivors on
qunari so it's not clear yet if his
sister's survival might have been a
story claimer Marva told him to keep him
hopeful or maybe something she knew
Cassie and believed but never had the
heart to tell him to stop believing it
but episode 1 did prove that there was
some qinari girl in that morelana one
brothel and I do not buy the Imperial
cover story that the planet is toxic
forever and ever in fact that giant pit
that young Cassian walked up to I
believe we have seen in other shots and
trailers a pit now filled with water and
used to build some Imperial construction
so I do think that mystery is leading
somewhere part of gas orders let's have
a full audit of all hyperspace Lanes
leading to odd mantel on my desk by this
time
tomorrow yes ORD mantel was first
mentioned in Empire Strikes Back I
thought you had decided to stay well the
Bounty Hunter we ran into an Ord Mandel
changed my mind this planet has since
been visited in Darth mauls on a death
mirror comics and an episode the bad
batch at this point in history it's
being used as an imperial Shipyard 11
accuses Miro of overreach and Miro
doesn't match to use the emergency act
to access Imperial records without
sanction but reframes the argument to
say their jurisdictional boundaries
should not apply here I'd like to know
if anyone here believes the Rebellion
plans its actions around the
artificially constructed boundaries of
our sectors major part of gods created
those sectors as organizing principles
not personal play things do you really
think the rebels care about the lines we
draw on maps yes she's saying by
redrawing the maps The Empire siled its
oversight from overseeing how Rebel
activity might transgress those
jurisdictions and particast to his
credit can't help but agree he reassigns
marlotto 1 and pharynx from blevant to
Miro but he does warn her to watch her
back onto the planet niamos which almost
sounds like Miami both in its name and
the German music Nicholas Hotel can pose
for it
[Music]
but they actually shot this in the UK
coastal town of Cleveland using the same
Stone Terraces laid into the water and
the rocky sea walls of course they added
in these massive resort hotels and if
you look in the distance a galactic
Cruise liner cassia now going by the
Alias Keith girgo has a woman companion
Wendy who asks so if you get the Piezo
again that is the snack Boot and the
hollow ad on course on earlier probably
something we'll be able to buy a
Galaxy's Edge soon enough Cassian passes
this dude with a Droid Leg playing a
handheld version of tajaric that's a
board game shooting R2 are playing on
the Falcon Imperial probe droids fly
overhead and he gets stopped by this
Stormtrooper wearing the same tan as
short trooper armor is a scare of
Troopers in Rogue one you were part of
it part of what don't play dumb if this
voice sounds familiar it's an upgraded
to Cameo by Sam Whitworth voice of maul
in the Star Wars animated series what
were even tweeted this line confirming
it this Trooper calls over a KX unit who
initially walks up the beach all sexy
like like Ursula Andress and doctor no
so hot this Droid but the trooper says
hang on to this one for me I want to
check the shelter
oh we get this Imperial choking Motif
again and to be clear this KX unit is
not k2so or will not be k2so this one is
voiced by Aidan cook who also did Dr
guapa last episode the introduction
between Cassian and k2so is already
codified in Star Wars Canon it's
explored in the Rogue one Cassian and
k2so comic where Cassian wipes his
memory and reprograms him on the planet
wekako and then we cut to this courtroom
cooled by this blade fan with an
imperial Crest the judge eats what looks
like pistachios and uses this old school
manual credit card swiper to print out
their Imperial rap sheets the guy right
before Cassie gets charged with walking
and Unleashed massive massives are the
Tuscan dogs from Tatooine this rap sheet
actually reads name Richard Stevenson
crime failure to follow Imperial command
anti-imperial vandalism sentence five
years yeah the judge called out four
months for this guy in different crimes
they just clearly shot close-ups of
different rap sheets than what the
dialogue says cassian's charge used to
be a six month sentence but thanks to
the new Imperial edicts as a result of
His Rebel success it goes up to six
years and his orbash rap sheet stuck in
another inside joke named Keith Seymour
crime suspected or sensitivity
assaulting an imperial officer sentenced
25 years Keith Seymour is very talented
Star Wars concept artist the episode
ends back with Cyril Karn in the Bureau
of Standards his brown suit swapped out
for a gray suit that matches everyone
else's he is unable to stand out wearing
a kind of prison uniform his eyes scan
lines and lines of numbers again very
much like Severance but he looks up and
to the left as he did in the very first
shot there he was looking at the window
looking for sunlight now he looks up at
us at the camera as if at a security
camera monitoring him he is in a prison
of Another Kind Cyril and Cassian both
incarcerated victims of their own
Ambitions you can follow me on Tick Tock
Instagram and Twitter at eat a boss
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]